I care so much about this project we've
had it for six years my mom and I
believe in the message Selena Gomez is
an international superstar but this time
the 24 year old is stepping behind the
camera to executive produce a new
Netflix series called 13 reasons why
what is the difference between Selena
the EP and Selena the star the actress
the singer not much I'm about to tell
you the story of my life more
specifically why my life ended you have
been so candid and open about how this
material really hit close to home for
you what kind of conversations do you
hope are generated from this series I'm
really big on vulnerability I think
people are really scared to be honest
with themselves and strength is looked
upon as
oh I'm strong I don't need anything I
can't I can handle everything and that's
just not the truth and I think kids
especially with social media sometimes
they just feel a little claustrophobic
and I don't think their voice is
actually being heard and I think that's
the message I want I want people to know
that every every single life is valuable
that their voice can be heard and that
there are people who are willing to be
there for them speaking of strength you
just seem so happy and like you have
this renewed perspective on life and
your career lately how accurate is that
very I think it's kind of telling I'm
very honest though in general I feel
like you could be able to see it in my
face and I love what I'm doing right now
it's enjoying my life and I'm getting to
do things that I'm passionate about with
the people that I love and we love the
cover of your song on this soundtrack
[Music]
can you tease what's coming up for your
own album I don't know I think I think
people are gonna be a little surprised
I'm excited for what's coming
[Music]